[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde à la une ce soir cette question
faut-il durcir le confinement les
chiffres de contamination reste très
élevé les services de réanimation se
remplissent à grande vitesse et certains
plaident donc pour un tour de vis
supplémentaire fermer les écoles
interdire les visites en ehpad ou
sanctionner les malades qui ne s'isole
pas tout est possible mais à quel prix
notre grand témoin ce soir le philosophe
et physicien etienne klein pour son
livre le goût du vrai il nous livrera
son regard sur la gestion de cette
pandémie
ces discours de scientifiques qui se
contredisent et notre propre rapport à
la vérité c'est passionnant vous verrez
et comme tous les vendredis notre
bloc-notes avec nos chroniqueurs qui
auront un accent très américain ce soir
présidentielle oblige on compte sur vous
pour réagir sur les réseaux sociaux avec
le mot-clé cgr
voilà pour le sommaire place au débat
présent
[Musique]
et pour débattre de ce confinement et
d'un éventuel tour de vis supplémentaire
j'accueille sur ce plateau
djillali annane bonsoir vous êtes chef
du service de médecine intensive et de
réanimation à l'hôpital de garches
philippe gosselin bonsoir bonsoir elle
vous êtes député et les républicains de
la manche épurée de distance en liaison
vidéo parce que on ne peut pas
accueillir tout le monde sur ce plateau
pour cause de protocole sanitaire erwan
balanant bonsoir vous êtes député modem
du finistère en direct du finistère
la deuxième vague sera donc plus haute
et plus longue que la première ses
propos c'est olivier ferrand qui les a
tenus et il relance donc le débat avec
cette question est-ce qu'il faut durcir
le confinement est ce que la france est
trop laxiste chacun y va de son idée
pour stopper cette tant d'ennemis c'est
la chronique de stéphane blakowski
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane bonsoir clément bonsoir
à 12 heures alors stéphane si j'ai bien
compris si j'ai bien compris comment on
se demande aujourd'hui si les règles
d'une nouveau confinement ne seront pas
trop souple alors nos fidèles
téléspectateurs dont peut-être trouvé ça
bizarre parce que mardi dernier
on se pose est exactement la question
inverse dans ce même studio est ce que
les règles du nouveau confinement ne
sont pas trop stricte et on pensait bien
sûr là aux petits commerçants baissent
qu'il chante comme la donne c'est que
c'est maintenant jérôme salomon donc le
directeur de la santé publique écrit une
note confidentielle pour tirer le signal
d'alarmé enfin pas si confidentiel que
ça évidemment la note puisque on l'a
retrouvé ce matin dans la presse voyez
c'était dans le figaro et lui il trouve
que ce n'est pas assez stricte
alors qu'est ce qui dit justement dans
cette note bon en gros ce qu'ils disent
et qu' il faudrait certainement revenir
aux règles plus strictes que celles qui
étaient appliquées lors du premier
confinement donc par exemple ne pas
autoriser les visites dans les ehpad
il faudrait aussi fermer les services
publics et puis aussi fermer les
établissements scolaires ce qui était le
cas je vous rappel en mars avril
alors est-ce qu'il n'a pas été en partie
entendue avec ce protocole sanitaire qui
est renforcée dans les lycées si ce
matin jean michel blanquer a annoncé ça
sans doute un peu à contrecoeur parce
qu'ils ne voulaient pas le faire au
départ mais que 50% des cours serait
fait la distance dans les lycées ou a
pas forcément être simple organiser
d'ici lundi les professeurs les
enseignants ont déjà prévu une journée
de grève et puis ils réclament aussi
qu'on est en-deça au collège après tout
ça ça paraît
logique en réalité un 6/6 ce confinement
des mesures vous allez voir c'est ce qui
manque alors une des mesures envisagées
l'appareil on lit ça dans la presse il
ya des fuites un peu partout donc on
lisait ce matin dans notre grand
quotidien du soir qu'on envisageait au
gouvernement réfléchissait à un
confinement des plus vulnérables
depuis le début c'est quelque chose qui
paraît un peu logique on on a des
journées a déjà parlé pendant la
première il nous rappelle que 92 % des
décès liés aux que vite son concernent
des plus de 65 ans m'enfin quand on fait
un peu le calcul si on parle tous les
personnes vulnérables donc tu as des
seniors mais il ya aussi les gens obèses
c'est certain qu'ils sont fragilisés par
des maladies ça prêt d'environ 20
millions de personnes a confiné pendant
que les 47 autres millions on va créer à
leurs occupations et ça le président
macron a plusieurs fois répété que non
il était contre cette discrimination
donc alors si cette option est rejetée
qu'est ce qui nous reste
écoutez vous savez qu'en france on n'a
pas de pétrole mais on a des idées
voilà ce fait les idées c'est pas
simplement donc jeu on fait une liste
pas exhaustive du côté des médecins par
exemple ça c'était ce matin je crois sur
lci professeur pialoux lui plaidé pour
le port du masque à la maison enfin
comment comment vérifier qu'on porte le
masque à la maison parce que ce que les
policiers vont pouvoir taper pour dire
attention à votre masque un autre
médecin qu'on connaît bien qui est
souvent venu ici qu'est le docteur
blachier violée par lui était pour le
confinement des personnes les plus âgées
cette semaine il faut aussi faire
attention aux jeunes dont qui proposait
des sanctions des amendes très très
forte 10000 euros pour les jeunes qui
organisent des fêtes un peu clandestine
pour continuer à s'amuser côté des
politiques voilà chacun sait un peu de
d'avoir une idée donc dit nicolas dupont
aignan a perdu de vue revient avec que
l'idée de rouvrir l'hôpital militaire du
val de grâce à paris est fermée depuis
cinq ans au parti radical là aussi y ont
fait des propositions peut-être plus
sérieuses et l'idée de
faire généraliser les tests salivaires à
l'ensemble de la population de manière
très massives comme ça peut faire dans
les pays d'asie jeu j'y repense là
maintenant et isabelle borne elle aussi
a brandi un peu le bâton disant
attention va sanctionner ceux qui ne
respecte pas strictement le télétravail
donc ça ça nous arrangerait pas moi
j'aimerais pas évidemment c'est là qu'on
se rend chez moi mais vous y accrochez
persie est président et elles sont
nombreuses
ce qu'il faut c'est tranché c'est donc
la question qu'on se pose que va décider
le gouvernement et quand merci à vous
stéphane alors on débatte évidemment
avec nos invités
djillali annane de votre côté vous êtes
sur quelles lignes vous êtes d'accord
avec alors c'est pas une foire aux idées
mais il ya des il ya du bon dans tout ce
qu'on a entendu de ce que dit stéphane
ya des mesures que vous souhaiteriez
voir appliquer aujourd'hui
prenons le la question à l'envers en
fait je crois que le confinement
sélectif et est probablement une fausse
bonne idée
d'abord l'efficacité sanitaire va
confinement sélectif paraît assez peu
crédible
on le voit bien le confinement partiel à
adapter comme on dit aujourd'hui est en
train de rhodes de ratèrent de ne pas de
produire ses effets
deuxièmement les personnes n'est pas
trop tôt pour en juger selon vos quand
une fois le virus galope voyez il galope
donc si nous on comprend quinze jours
trois semaines pour juger de l'impact
sur les provocations du virus des
mesures qui sont prises
ça paraît pourtant se dit puisque les
victimes sont vraiment les personnes
âgées pourquoi ne pas cibler justement
son cas une raison assez simple de mon
point de vue flamand prévoit elle va
écouter moi je vous expliquais que ce
que dans ma vie celle que je constate
sur le travail sur sur mon lieu de
travail on constate plusieurs choses
c'est d'abord l'âge moyen des patients
en réanimation à c'est plutôt dans mon
service 60 ans et c'est en moyenne 61 en
général dans les services de réanimation
donc il faudra me dire à quel niveau
d'âge on va on va dire que les personnes
sont fragiles ou pas deuxièmement les
patients qui sont du grand âge ou ceux
qui ont des pathologies
associés qui sont a priori des gens
vulnérables aujourd'hui sont ceux qui
respectent le plus les gestes barrière
se sont ceux qui sont le plus prudent
vis-à-vis de la transmission du virus et
donc d'une certaine façon je pense qu'à
confinement sélectif à la fois serait
pas efficace sur le plan sanitaire et
deuxièmement ce serait une double peine
pour les personnes vulnérables parce que
ce sont elles qui font plus volontiers
les formes graves et d'autre part ce
sont elles qui sont plutôt victimes que
les personnes qui propagent le virus et
donc si on veut stopper la propagation
du virus
il faut cibler les le point de départ de
ces propagation du virus
philippe gosselin quand vous entendez le
professeur gillian end il faut faire
quelque chose là ça suffit pas le virus
galope quand même votre groupe a fait
pression en début de semaine et vous
vous êtes montés en première ligne pour
défendre l'ouverture de ces petits
commerçants jugées non essentielles vous
dit pas bon peut-être qu'on aurait dû
être
mais nous en retrait sur maintenant
parce que la difficulté c'est qu'on a de
la part de l'état du gouvernement des
signaux contradictoires
je ne vois pas en quoi il y aurait
contradiction a demandé l'ouverture des
petits commerces ou les gestes les
protocoles sont respectées ou s'entasser
dans des supermarchés enfin très
honnêtement on parle de lieux de
concentration je pense que chez des
petits commerçants il n'y a pas plus de
concentration voire moins donc ça s'est
imposé en rajoutant un risque tout de
même de quoi qu'elle risque est il allé
plus il ya forcément des interactions
sociales dès lors que les patients et
pas dans un supermarché
bien sûr que si rayé le caractère
essentiel ou ou non mais à ce moment là
la réponse devait être clair et le
problème c'est que le gouvernement et
c'est sans doute la difficulté là je
cherche pas pinailler parce que là ça
flambe
moi je reprend les termes ça flambe et
personne ne le conteste et il faut agir
mais on a besoin de mesure claire
lisible et est donc facilement
acceptable à partir du moment où les
décisions prises donne le sentiment de
partir tous azimuts
forcément le penchant naturel c'est
d'essayer de voir si tous azimuts on ne
peut pas y arriver on voulait quelque
chose de clair mais gabriel
talent sur vous sur votre parti dans le
figaro ce matin l'éditeur et regarder
cette expression par d'un confinement
gruyère oui oui oui mais c'est le même
gabriel attal qui est capable de vous
dire un matin qui aura un couvre-feu à
paris c'était il ya deux jours de se
faire tacler une heure après par le
premier ministre donc quand on est porte
parole
on mesure ces propos et on les adapte là
il s'agit pas de d'enfermer l'opposition
dans un corner en dix ans l'opposition
est bête et méchante
je crois que nous avons besoin d'une
lutte collective ce que ne veut pas
comprendre le gouvernement sait que les
oppositions comme les élus locaux comme
un certain nombre de professions peuvent
faire un certain nombre de propositions
il y a des chiffres sanitaires qui sont
là incontournable et il faut faire
évidemment avec la question n'est pas de
savoir si on peut autoriser telle ou
telle profession etc
c'est plus nécessairement le sujet parce
qu'en effet les choses évoluent mais
c'est d'avoir des décisions qui
apparaissent cohérente réfléchi
peut-être peu de décisions mais qui soit
clairement applicables ça c'est l'enjeu
principal
on va aller voir erwan balanant pour
quand même avoir un peu le la parole de
la majorité pour vous et rwe de balanod
ils se trouvent ou le point d'équilibré
a été trouvé aujourd'hui où il faut
encore ajuster si l'on peut dire ce
confinement
mais depuis le début de la crise et puis
mois de marche
cette crise nous apprend quoi nous
apprend à être humble et lucide sur les
situations et donc avoir des évolutions
de décision j'ai envie de dire au fil
des jours
donc c'est ça l'enjeu l'enjeu c'est
d'être suffisamment agile pour s'adapter
moi je suis très surpris de la position
de des républicains qui est qui on sent
bien aujourd'hui devant l'ampleur de la
vague sont en train de se dire on a
peut-être fait une bêtise en étant arc
bouté sur ses histoires de petits
commerces
moi moi je vais vous dire ma position
sur ces espèces de petits commerces
quand j'ai vu les premiers décrets je me
suis dit aussi je me suis dit il ya
quand même une injustice on a
immédiatement remonter le sujet pour
faire évoluer et pour fermer le non
essentiels à l'intérieur des grandes
surfaces et moi j'avoue que ma position
elle a très vite évoluer aussi parce que
j'ai vu l'ampleur et j'ai vu les
chiffres qui nous ont été fournis et qui
sont fournis à tout le monde d'ailleurs
et que les républicains avec
et moi je me suis dit on ne peut pas
tenir cette position il faut avoir une
tenue une res position de deux n'ont pas
de responsabilité parce que si je dis ça
vous allez croire que vous ne seriez pas
responsable et moi je sais que cela je
sais que la plupart des ténors de la
majorité de l'opposition sont également
le responsable
mais je suis sont bons mais non mais je
le donne à ce jeu là je sais pas de
l'ironie merci de le noter effectivement
par contre je pense qu'il ne faut pas
tomber dans la facilité et parfois oui
ça peut être facile de dire il y à un
justice le gouvernement fait n'importe
quoi
je comprends bien la logique un peu
politicienne mais aujourd'hui je crois
que on a tous intérêt à rester humble et
lucide et à continuer à nous adapter au
fil de l'eau et à nous adapter suivant
les situations suivantes la montée
suivant peut-être des nouvelles
solutions qui pourraient arriver et qui
pourrait être proposé parce que les
acteurs proposent aussi des solutions
je crois que c'est la ligne qu'il faut
avoir sur le long sur le long terme sur
ce virus
alors justement on va on va se pencher
sur les solutions mais d'abord je
voudrais qu'on regarde quelques chiffres
comme quand même pour voir exactement où
on en est aujourd'hui en france donc
hier
vous voyez c'est chez 58 mille quarante
six nouveaux cas c'est un record 1
la france est le pays le plus touché
d'europe avec 1 million 600 mille cas
depuis le début des temps début mai
qu'en proportion environ 85 % des lits
de réanimation sont aujourd'hui occupés
alors on débat donc de cet éventuel tour
de vis supplémentaire en france mais
qu'est ce que font les autres pays qui
sont également touchées par cette
pandémie
on va s'intéresser à deux points précis
qui font débat aujourd'hui
d'un côté l'isolément des malades et
puis de l'autre le contrôle du respect
du confinement par toute la population
sur ces deux points est ce que la france
est plus laxiste que les autres examens
gavât a enquêté avec hélène bonduelle et
cléa jouanno une surfer sorti de l'eau
par des policiers en espagne son crime
être positive au qu'ovide 19 et ne pas
avoir respecté son isolement
certains pays appliquent des mesures
drastiques pour s'assurer que les
personnes contaminées et leurs contacts
ne sortent pas de chez elle en asie par
exemple à taïwan si vous êtes positif au
qu'ovide on vous donne un smartphone
avec un gps
ce n'est pas un cadeau mais un moyen
pour la police 2
surveillez vos déplacements il y a aussi
des amendes très élevées si vous ne
respectez pas les règles à singapour
c'est 6000 euros et jusqu'à six mois de
prison au royaume-uni s'isoler après un
test positif est devenue une obligation
légale sous peine de dix mille euros
damende en france rien de tel
le pays mis sur la responsabilité
individuelle
j'ai effectivement des mois des
collègues qui ont été positifs et qui se
sont déclarés déclaré et moi j'ai j'ai
été signalé comme cas contacts c'est
alors moi je n'ai pas été contacté je
crois qu'il a été contacté en fait mais
je j'ai pris des mesures en fait seul je
sais pas je n'ai pas été contacté mais
je me suis effectivement par mesure de
prévention les seuls contravention
existantes valent pour non respect du
confinement si vous êtes contrôlés sans
votre fameuse attestation il vous en
coûtera 135 euros damende 3750 euros si
vous faute et trois fois dans le mois
mais force est de constater que pour se
re confinement les contrôles sont peu
intense alors le confinement n'est pas
toujours respectée sans masque parce que
je sors fumée promener mon chien est
posté mon courrier voilà sans
attestation
il n'y a aucun contrôle comme moi dans
mon entourage et beaucoup de gens qui se
réunissent chez les uns et chez les
autres pour faire des dîners face à
cette nouvelle vague la france pourrait
être tenté de muscler son jeu mais pour
susciter l'adhésion de la population
faut-il préférer la carotte ou le bâton
djillali annane vous vous positionnez
comment dans ce débat est ce que vous
vous souhaiteriez par exemple des
amendes dissuasives pour les personnes
malades qui ne respectent pas
d'isolement et la dissuasion sûre que
c'est une chose ça peut peut-être ça
peut peut-être marcher je sais pas
comment la majorité des français
seraient capables de payer 10 euros
damende enfin bon et bien sûr tout je
pense qu'on se pose pas les bonnes
questions par une fois le et pourtant le
répètent tous depuis le début de
l'épidémie le virus il se propage d'une
personne à une autre
si l'on veut stopper la propagation du
virus
il faut limiter le plus possible les
contacts entre les personnes
et donc en mars quand le confinement
total est généralisé a été opéré il a
été rapidement et radicalement efficace
serre avant même que les chiffres
tombent au bout de quinze jours trois
semaines la tension a cédé au niveau de
la première ligne c'est un déni des
services de réanimation on l'a senti ça
c'est pour éteindre l'incendié mais
c'est de ça dont il s'agit à court terme
c'est d'éteindre la santé parce que ça
aujourd'hui
non le confinement n'est pas respecte
aujourd'hui on est en train de le rater
collectivement entre petit 1 les gens
qui ne respectent pas les règles du jeu
petit 2 les dérogations qui sont trop
nombreuses et pas justifié et peu petit
roi des mesures qui ne sont pas prises
alors qu'elle ne devrait être prise
franchement le maintien par exemple des
lycées ouverts est assez
incompréhensible certes ya pas de
différence mais complètement les lycées
pas seulement à coup sûr les lycées et
les collèges
parce que on sait bien que dans cette
catégorie de jeunes adultes et
d'adolescents
eh bien il est beaucoup plus difficile
de faire respecter les règles sanitaires
on le voit bien la quadrature du cercle
au moment du déjeuner et des cantines et
on voit bien donc on a là des endroits
où le virus peut continuer d'accélérer
sa circulation pas simplement de
circuler mais d'accélérer sa circulation
alors ça c'est quelque chose qui élisait
de sacrifier une génération des frais
privés d'école qui serait groupe
montagne crise économique et sociale ça
vous pas non plus pourquoi on nous dit
d'emblée que on va sacrifier une
génération parce qu'on va fermer les
lycées pendant 15 jours ou un mois
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on ne délivre pas
de l'enseignement dans les universités
elles sont fermées
je suis moi-même doyen de la faculté je
peux vous garantir que dans ma faculté
de médecine bien évidemment l'université
fermée mais les enseignements à distance
continue et la capacité peut-être des
lycéens à suivre un enseignement à
distance et pas forcément la même que
celle d'un étudiant on va dire mais ça
n'est pas vit encore une fois il faut
s'adapter c'est toute une génération et
c'est transitoire et donc ça le sera
d'autant plus transitoire que les
mesures que l'on prenne aujourd'hui sont
vraiment efficaces sinon tu auras tu le
confinement qu'est ce qui va se passer
alors quinze jours trois semaines va
dire bahamas
continue de galoper il continue dans les
cas donc on va renforcer dans quinze 15
jours trois semaines le confinement avec
un confinement généralisée et au lieu
d'être bloquée jusqu'à début décembre va
être bloquée jusqu'au printemps
erwan balanant veut réagir quand même
sur cette question de fermer les lycées
on vous écoute
voilà on a les deux voies et le
gouvernement l'a prévu et le ministre on
l'a vu très rapidement fermé ou laisser
les lycées le complètement ouvert n'est
pas satisfaisant donc décide de passer
sur une 2011 voilà on évolue on est
agile et ont fait un choix que vous plus
vous est peut-être jugé un entre deux
mais aujourd'hui moi je partage pas
votre idée cette professeur parce que
fermer complètement les lycées et
laisser des enfants aujourd'hui qui ont
déjà souffert pendant un bon moment
quand il était en première es qui ont
maintenant par exemple sont en terminale
pour préparer le pack et c'est compliqué
pour ces enfants et les enfants n'ont
pas le degré des lycées a surtout les
lycéens qui en sont seconds n'ont pas le
degré de maturité d'un élève d'un
l'étudiante qui est à la faculté donc
c'est compliqué il faut trouver un juste
milieu on peut pas ne pas on peut pas
laisser ses enfants sans instruction on
a vu les dégâts que ça avait eu pendant
la première vague et je pense que on
peut pas non plus se dire qu'on va faire
du stop and go sans arrêt comme comme
vous semblerez le dire moi je pense
qu'il faut trouver mais on doit vous
écoutez aussi on va écouter les
professeurs la science est évident mais
on doit s'adapter pour avoir une vie qui
continue
une vie qui continue dans le respect de
la santé de chacun mais aussi dans le
respect de la vie tout simplement je
parle même pas de l'économie de la vie
c'est à dire que nous sommes des êtres
humains et nous avons besoin de vivre
nous avons besoin de moi je suis confiné
parce que j'ai vu que j'étais quatre
contacts depuis une semaine je suis chez
moi depuis une semaine je suis pas le
plus à plaindre je suis dans une maison
à maison en bretagne
enfin franchement c'est pas une vie non
plus donc on va il faut il faut vraiment
qu'on arrive à trouver des méthodes de
l'agilité des et voilà une nouvelle
façon de ville pour pouvoir vivre tout
simplement
avec ce virus et ça va pas être simple
et je conçois je conçois et je comprends
vos inquiétudes aussi sur le fait qu' un
confinement majeur au total serait
certainement satisfaisant
les américains parce que vous avez pas
eu beaucoup la parole vous vous
réagissez ou envoyer sous peu la tête la
revue et bien sûr parce qu'encore une
fois il faut arrêter ce genre de
discours ne va pas ça on va pas
installer à une stratégie de stop and go
advitam eternam
si on est dans cette situation critique
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'on a été
sourd aux appels du terrain fin août
début septembre qui expliquer très
clairement qu'on allait se retrouver
on l'avait date et à la semaine près
cette situation
donc ça quand même il faut arrêter de
dire c'est bien le fait que l'on n'a pas
su anticiper les choses qu'on ne s'est
pas préparé à cette deuxième vague qu'on
la subit de plein fouet
donc qui fait référence au professeur
delfraissy qui mi septembre a dit les
décisions difficiles à prendre et il n'a
pas été entendu et ça ça me non qu'on ne
voit pas que le comité scientifique est
une chose importante mais je le dis on
le plusieurs à le dire ce qui se passe
sur le terrain
ce que nous nous voyons au quotidien
vous savez on est on est les premiers à
voir les choses arriver la deuxième
vague où l'a vu arriver avant tout le
monde
on la sicalait on n'a pas été pris au
sérieux quand on a expliqué que cette
deuxième vague serait pire que la
première
au début on n'a pas été pris au sérieux
et on avait dit vous savez le jour où on
rencontra le nombre d'admissions en
réanimation tous les jours ce jour-là
l'épidémie aura on aura perdu le
contrôle de l'épidémie et on sera de
nouveau en pleine situation
catastrophique et légaux ça c'est vrai
que la situation est extrêmement
difficile à gérer et je crois que
personne ne peut prétendre avoir la
solution donc beaucoup de modestie je
rejoins erwan balanant sur ce point
beaucoup de modestie y compris de la
part de l'opposition mais quand même
quelques points quand on a un président
de la république qui le 14 juillet nous
dit écoute et voilà on aura sans doute
une seconde vague mais nous serons prêts
tout sera prêt etc
quant au mois de septembre on nous dit
oui il y aura quelques éléments mais on
va voir
et puis qu'on nous dit on va ouvrir le
couvre feu mais en même temps partait en
vacances de la toussaint comme si de
rien n'était vous voyez bien que il ya
quand même de l'illogisme dans tout ça
il n'y a pas de décisions claires et
carrées et moi je réclamais et je
réclame toujours est à nouveau
la cohérence dans les décisions je
maintiens que le signal qu'ils étaient
envoyés aux petits commerçants était un
mauvais signal à partir du moment où on
considérer que tout était au vert dans
les supermarchés ça peut paraître du
détail anecdotique par rapport aux
enjeux d'aujourd'hui mais c'est une
question d'équilibré d'égalité et
d'acceptabilité des décisions à partir
du moment où les choses sont carrées et
bien sûr évolutive
il est évident qu'une décision
d'aujourd'hui ne sera pas celle de
demain et il faut sans doute resserré la
vis si on ne veut pas que les par
exemple lycées vous vous souhaitez les
fermes et aujourd'hui ils ne souhaitent
pas aujourd'hui parce que ça me parait
effectivement plein d'inconvénients pour
des jeunes qui depuis sept huit mois
sont en réalité quasiment déscolarisés
même s'il ya eu depuis la rentrée pas
mal de choses et les lycées ont été
protégés je pense à des étudiants moi
j'ai des étudiants à sciences po je les
ai vus deux fois et encore en groupe en
groupe et en été en hybride là c'est
fini on va faire passer les oraux par
vision etc
c'est pas si simple comment les évalue
moi j'en ai certains qui me l'ont dit
qu'ils sont pas très bien on a aussi des
étudiants alors là c'est peut-être pas
les lycéens et des étudiants qui
aujourd'hui sont terrés dans leurs
petites chambres du crous sont pas chez
eux ne peuvent pas bosser n'ont pas de
petits boulots et non pas des familles
qui peuvent les aider
comment on fait pour eux enfin moi je
suis aussi très inquiet là c'est pas une
question de droite gauche haut je crois
qu on partage tous ces questions là donc
il ya les enjeux effectivement
sanitaires qui sont très très fort mais
il faut qu'à côté on puisse avoir un
équilibre ou en tout cas une réponse
très concrète si on va au delà
est ce que je regrette c'est
qu'aujourd'hui en réalité et je le dis
encore une fois avec simplicité et
beaucoup de prudence
mais je regrette qu'on en soit à céder
pratiquement à la panique on a
l'impression qu' il n'y a pas de plan
organisé ça vient pas de vous sur le
plan scientifique et médicale on a
l'impression qu'en gros il n'ya pas
grand-chose déstabiliser je comprends
encore une fois que ça soit déroutant
mais on a quand même normalement six
mois derrière nous on a l'impression
encore au mois de mars que ce que
répondez-vous à ce manque d'anticipation
de préparation face à cette seconde
vague c'est moi je suis pas d'accord
avec cette idée qui a pas eu de but qui
a eu un manque d'anticipation c'est pas
vrai et le ministre vers on l'a bien
rappelé il ya un certain nombre de
choses qui ont été faibles je suis parti
faire en cinq minutes c'est évident mais
attendez attendez moi moi je veux bien
que vous fassiez le reproche parfois du
manque de cohérence cher philippe
gosselin et j'aimerais que l'opposition
ce ch'ti cohérente dans son opposition
et qu'elle réclame pas un moment
certaines choses pour nous dire ensuite
qu'on n'a pas été assez vite par exemple
je prends l'exemple je sens bien la
petite musique dans quelques jours vous
allez nous faire le reproche de ne pas
avoir confiné sitôt vous même qui nous
disiez qu'il fallait pas pour chiner les
petits commerces et donc pas chez moi je
le deviens et je comprends la position
du du professeur parce que au mois de
septembre
on voyait effectivement que ça devenait
tendue mais qui aurait pu politiquement
dès le mois de septembre prendre cette
décision alors que les indicateurs
n'étaient pas du tout pour le grand
public est désastreux l'acceptation
sociale de la mesure et âme au moins eu
vers l'essai nous révèle quand même on
est dans un état d'urgence mais j'avais
tous les moyens pour y parvenir on veut
se donner les clés on vous avait
relancés par leur sens de l'état
d'urgence pas au mois de juin on est en
train de faire la prolongation des bêtas
d'urgence c'est qu'on est en train de
voir le tuilage pour en sortir vous nous
dites il faut l'arrêter on se reverra si
on en a besoin on voulait la solution
non mais je peux pas laisser dire ça on
vous dit erwan balanant on vous et moi
associer le parlement c'est pas la même
chose
oui elle le parle au noyer nous faut
discuter non c'est pas vrai j'ai pas
l'impression que parlement j'ai
l'intention de la presse mais c'est la
réalité il ya eu des débats la nuit
dernière on a eu heureusement qu'ils
allaient vous n'étiez pas là d'ailleurs
arrivé j'étais pas là
car wash baladant c était chez lui il
n'y a pas de reproche là dessus mais non
ça on est bien d'accord je pleurais pas
de chez vous personnellement mais je
parlais de la majorité qui n'était pas
là donc moi ce que je vais dire oui
c'est difficile et oui parfois des
mesures sont prises à un moment donné et
on doit les adapter ce qui peut laisser
drame
et moi je laisse dans ces cas là je
retourne à la majorité à l'opposition
pardon cette idée d'être également
cohérent dans leur opposition et de
garder le même cap
alors c'est pas vous mais par exemple je
prends l'exemple de monsieur dupont
aignan qui le cède ou non à ces
effectivement pas nous et je suis désolé
mais dit mais c'est la sixième ont même
pas ce qui est je sais où la crise est
finie est ce que devrait nous dire
monsieur macron c'est la crise et
philippe 7 août pour qu'il ya eu
dernièrement s'il ya quelques jours nous
disent mais vous avez rien anticipé vous
n'avez rien vous voyez bien que c'est
extrêmement compliqué et moi je le redis
c'est tendu posture bien la division 1a
calme aurait été impossible à concevoir
un point de vue le solde de leur
acceptation par l'associé on a bien
compris votre point de vue à roanne
balanant on va devoir s'arrêter là pour
ce pour ce débat merci à tous les trois
des deux venue sur le plateau de ça vous
regarde pour tous les deux et à erwan
balanant d'avoir été avec nous à
distance on va rester sur cette
thématique sanitaire parce que c'est
clairement ce qui a animé les débats
vous l'avez compris cette semaine à
l'assemblée c'est la chronique de thomas
des prêts et il ya eu du spectacle dans
l'hémicycle cette semaine c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire thomas oui exactement
clément cette semaine encore l'actualité
était riche ici à l'assemblée et
forcément les équipes web dès le cp
étaient aux premières loges pour vous
faire vivre sur les réseaux sociaux ce
qui se passait ici dans l'hémicycle
voici ce qu'il ne fallait pas louper
cette semaine
[Musique]
alors cette semaine il ya un événement
qui à lui seul fait à l'actualité de
l'assemblée le vote sur l'état d'urgence
sanitaire à lui seul cet événement
compile les trois extraits les plus
forts sur les réseaux sociaux
dell cpm il ya d'abord le vote par les
députés de l'opposition d'un amendement
réduisant la durée de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
la réponse d'olivier ferrand très énervé
face à cette décision
et puis la riposte du président des
républicains christian jacob
mais on commence par cette vidéo c'est
elle qui a mis le feu aux poudres
on est un mardi soir il est 21h30 les
députés les républicains aidés par les
oppositions vote un amendement réduisant
la durée de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
même la présidente de la séance a du mal
à y croire scène rare dans l'hémicycle
qui est pour et qui est contre à il faut
compter donc
je vais faire l'appel d'ong qui est pour
lever le doigt
ils ont 18 84 84 85
qui est contre 207 206 il est adopté
le 16
alors quelques minutes plus tard le
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
débarque dans l'hémicycle il revient
d'une visite dans un hôpital avec le
premier ministre c'est la séquence de la
semaine le ministre de la santé peine à
garder son calme devant les députés
dans la première chambre il avait un
jeune homme de 28 ans de 28 ans en coma
intubé et ventilé
c'est ça la réalité mesdames et
messieurs les députés voulaient valentin
fatalité elle est là la réalité de nos
hôpitaux
elle est là la réalité de vos tutoz
c'est un la réalité le nombre d'hôpitaux
et autres à de débattre de sujets alors
que nous soyons pas trop fort et débits
de cette manière-là dans nos hôpitaux
on m'a expliqué que les députés de
l'opposition étaient debout pour
applaudir le fait qu'ils aient des
beautés la faim l'état d'urgence
sanitaire aux minots à la mi décembre et
la fin du confinement à la fin novembre
quoi qu'il arrive dans notre pays le
décalage était tellement total que j'ai
décidé de venir dans cette mythique ce
soir bien sûr la réponse d'olivier
ferrand on a entraîné d'autres garder
cette réaction celle du président des
républicains christian jacob
il n'a pas du tout goûté à la réflexion
du ministre de la santé monsieur le
ministre
vos propos étaient indignes et vous avez
été indigne vous avez été indigne parce
que qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer les yeux dans les yeux qu'il
n'y a pas plus de concentration de
population et de risques de transmission
du virus dans les transports en commun
dans les grandes surfaces qu'il peut y
en avoir
chez un coiffeur chez un cordonnier
c'est de la démagogie
vous avez été indigne des fonctions que
vous exercez voilà que mon rendez vous
la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
semaine à l'assemblée
merci thomas et un grand bravo aux
services web dès le cp puisqu'il fait
vraiment un superbe travail pour isoler
ces moments importants dans notre vie
parlementaire on passe à notre grand
témoin présent
[Musique]
bonsoir etienne klein alors vous êtes
philosophe des sciences vous êtes
physicien au cea commissariat à
l'énergie atomique et vous publier cet
ouvrage le goût du vrai c'est dans la
collection tracts chez gallimard alors
avant de parler de votre livre une
question un peu plus personnel vous êtes
un grand amoureux de la montagne des
grands espaces de la nature comment est
ce que vous vivez ce deuxième
confinement mais je peux pas pratiquer
l'alpinisme en tout cas pas le vrai don
jeu j'essaie de pratiquer ce que
j'appellerais l'alpinisme de l'âme c'est
à dire j'imagine qu'elle aussi en
montagne et ça suffit presque à me
rendre le confinement plus supportable
bon alors dans votre livre vous partez
d'un constat le constat d'un
affaiblissement de notre goût pour la
vérité la science a longtemps contribué
à établir justement des vérités
seulement aujourd'hui on a l'impression
que n'importe qui peut contester ce que
dit la science en lui opposant une
simple opinion comment est ce que vous
expliquez cela je pense que pendant la
crise qu'ont combien de traverser qu'on
traverse encore d'ailleurs il ya une
sorte de confusion entre la recherche et
la science on a fait comme si les deux
se confondent et or la science est un
corpus de connaissances bien établie qui
a pas lieu de remettre en cause sauf
grosse surprise par exemple la terre est
ronde
l'atom existe l'univers observable est
en expansion
les espèces vivantes évoluent ainsi de
la science ce corpus de connaissances
qui sûr et bien ils posent des questions
auxquelles nous ne savons pas répondre
et c'est pour cela que nous faisons de
la recherche donc la recherche et la
voir avec le doute
et quand on amalgame si on sait
recherche et bien le doute inhérents à
la recherche bien colonisé la science
elle-même et on dit dans une sorte de
recours si la science c'est le doute et
si la science et le doute
moi avec mon ressenti mes opinions les
croyances les préjugés
j'ai le droit de contester ce que
j'entends dire dans les scientifiques
mais c'est à dire que le concept de
vérité scientifique c'est s'est terminée
aujourd'hui dans notre société rasade de
vérité il est délicat à définir est même
philosophique mans donc moi je dirais
simplement que la science elle trouve
à l'issue d'une démarche très
particulière la bonne réponse à
certaines questions bien poser et si la
réponse fait consensus
alors on dit que c'est un résultat de
sciences ou une vérité scientifique est
aujourd'hui en effet ça ne suffit pas à
convaincre
on peut invoquer une forme de
relativisme pour dire que ce qui est dit
là et 10 en fait par une communauté
particulière que les vérités
scientifiques sont éphémères contextuel
culturel instrumentalisé et ses terrains
de sorte que en effet il ya à la fois un
désir de véracité parce que la
population est éduqué elle est formée
elle est informée il ya le souci de ne
pas être dupe et quand on entend trop de
gens dire la même chose on se demande
s'ils n'ont pas intérêt à dire ce qu'ils
disent plutôt qu'à honorer la vérité
mais ce désir de véracité qui est tout à
fait louable en démocratie
paradoxalement il vient alimenter l'idée
d'un déni de vérité s'il avait tenté
qu'on trouve une vérité on se demande si
elle est pas institutionnels culturels
éphémère bref on vient dé faire par un
sur deux jugements critiques généralisée
l'idée qu'il y à des vérités assuré et
c'est comme ça que le désir de véracité
finalement via abîmée l'idée qu'il ya
des vérités alors il ya la contestation
de la science et puis aussi la science
qui se contredit elle même on a pu le
voir dans cette actualité liée à la
pandémie
toutes ces controverses qui a pu avoir
entre entre scientifiques
ça facilite pas forcément la prise de
décision politique je vous propose de
regarder ce qu'on a dit devant la
commission d' enquête sur la gestion du
coronavirus l'ancien premier ministre
edouard philippe c'était à propos des
masques
j'ai dit 13h de tf1 que le port du
masque en population générale n'avait
aucun sens pourquoi est-ce que je les
dis parce qu'on me l'avait dit parce que
des médecins me l'avait dit parce que
c'était la doctrine qui n'a changé que
bien après qu'il le disait il les dit
avec assurance
parce que je pensais qu'il fallait
diffuser cette information qui résultait
de la batterie aujourd'hui la doctrine a
changé alors d'abord comment est ce que
vous vous expliquer que des
scientifiques disent blanc un jour noir
le lendemain sur des sujets comme cela
ça je sais pas quels sont les articles
dont on parle
faut bien comprendre que que la science
est une aventure collective c'est même
l'organisation collective de la
controverse scientifique donc d'écouter
un scientifique
ça n'est pas écouté la science et donc
il faudrait adorent j'ai beaucoup de
scientifiques et voir s'ils disent la
même chose s'ils disent la même chose il
s'agit d'un consensus
si c'est simplement un médecin
particulier qui le dit ça devient
peut-être son opinion et non pas
résultat qu'on peut qu'elle ici qualifié
de scientifiques et puis au départ on a
un terrain nouveau virus qu'on connaît
mal et dont il est normal de ne pas
savoir et de bâtir des décisions sur de
la connaissance ça c'est à dire qu'il ya
ya ya le fruit mais fait que mon avance
au fil de l'eau à dire on ne sait pas
parce qu'il ya besoin de réponses et des
décisions à prendre et je pense que on a
voulu aller au-delà de connaissances
pour assurer pour justifier des
décisions alors que normalement quand on
a le temps ce qui n'est pas le cas du
politique quand on a le temps et bien il
faut dire là on sait pas encore on va
travailler alors c'est trouver la
réponse justement où j'allais vous allez
sur ce terrain là on a vu un peu deux
attitudes au début de cette pandémie
dents du côté de l'exécutif on a duré 1
emmanuel macron très martial déclarant
la guerre aux coronavirus très sûr de
lui et puis on a vu un edouard philippe
plus prudent qui a reconnu notamment ici
même à l'assemblée nationale qui savait
pas et il l'a dit ouvertement
vous trouvez ça courageux de sa part
extrêmement courageux parce que quand
vous dites quand on est quand on est un
dirigeant un responsable politique il
faut aussi savoir prendre des décisions
un moment oui mais il faut assumer la
part d'un connaissances qui leur est
associé par exemple si un scientifique
vient la télévision est dit vous me
posez une question à laquelle j nous ne
connaissons pas la réponse par exemple
vous me demandez si quelqu'un qui a été
contacté qui a contracté le virus qui
est tombée malade peut à nouveau le
devenir malade par une seconde infection
au début de l'épidémie personne n'en
sait rien et donc je vais répondre à
votre question je ne sais pas mais si je
dis trop souvent je ne sais pas est ce
que vous allez me réalité non
autrement dit je serai médiatiquement
débordé par quelqu'un qui
qui dira ce qu'il pense au delà de ce
qu'il sait et qui nous rassure à part le
fait qu'il a l'air sûr de lui comment
vous jugez du coup cette gestion de la
crise cette gestion politique on en a
débattu avant que vous n'arriviez sur ce
plateau avec avec nos invités
quel regard vous portez vous l'addition
c'est extrêmement difficile car après
coup on peut juger et critiquer tout ce
qui a été fait ou dit mais c'est
extrêmement difficile parce que
évidemment il ya un conseil scientifique
les scientifiques disent aux politiques
ce qu'ils savent et aussi ce qu'ils ne
savent pas autrement dit et remplissent
un rôle de phares et balises
il est clair par des connaissances mais
aussi 10 les zones d'incertitude les
risques les dangers les catastrophes
possibles et le politique doit décider
en méconnaissance de course et mes
connaissances vie parce qu'il ya
d'autres paramètres à prendre en compte
mais pas que la santé d or il ya
l'économie à l'état psychique de la
population et donc c'est extrêmement
difficile et je pense qu'il faut un
tempérament assez solides pour assumer
une telle responsabilité sans craquer
nerveusement
alors il ya un autre défi que doivent
relever les
les dirigeants c'est qu'ils doivent
aussi faire la pédagogie de leur prise
de décision et là aussi il ya un
problème c'est à dire comment expliquer
des décisions quand les avis des
scientifiques change et du coup les
décisions elles mêmes sont obligés de
changer et parfois de se contredire on
est face à une équation voyez là moi je
toute l'allée la conférence de presse du
28 mars si ma mémoire est bonne et est
plutôt attiré j avais les politiques et
les scientifiques qui disaient ce qu'ils
savaient ce qu'ils ne savaient pas qui
c'est la pédagogie
oui mais ça c'est parce que je parle sur
la durée sur la dure alors on avait
l'occasion historique de faire de la
pédagogie d'expliquer jour après jour en
temps réel
qu'est ce que c'est que la méthodologie
de la science non récurrence de la
médecine et de la recherche en
épidémiologie expliquer ce que c'est
qu'un essai en double aveugle ce que
c'est qu'un essai randomisé ce que c'est
qu'une statistique
la différence entre corrélation et
causalité souvent confondu les deux
comme si on avait le droit de dire qu'il
a plus les grenouilles sous protêt ce
qu' il ya des bruits après la pluie et
donc on avait là une occasion de faire
dans les magazines et je pense qu'on l'a
raté parce qu'au lieu de faire de la
pédagogie on organisait ce qu'on
appelait des débats des clash entre
personnes qui ne sont pas d'accord alors
que débattre
étymologiquement cette amo du 12e siècle
qui veut dire ce qu'il faut faire pour
ne pas se battre c'est à dire argumenté
pratiquer une sorte de politesse de
l'esprit on laisse parler l'autre le cls
argumenté et l'autre ça dans beaucoup
d'endroits on a organisé des clashs et
on appelait ça des débats alors ça nous
on n'était absolument pas vous pensez
qu'on peut plus débattre aujourd'hui
dans notre société qu'on n'est pas
capable d'écouter un point de vue
différent du sien pense que les gens
modérés doivent s'exprimer sans
modération les gens qui ne sont pas
modérés ont beaucoup la parole il
polarise les discussions de sorte que
les gens modérés qui auraient des avis
très intéressant vers la loire ne sont
pas entendus et le débat si on veut
qu'il soit pertinent et aboutissent à
des conclusions en lesquels on puisse se
reconnaître
il a besoin de se dérouler d'une façon
assez modérée sinon ce sont les extrêmes
polarisé qui vont imposer des façons de
voir un peu comme sur les réseaux
sociaux on peut aimer ou ne pas aimer
sont d'abord besoin d'argumenter
et là ce sont les médias qui sont
responsables vous diriez de cette dérive
moi je cherche pas de bouc émissaire je
dis simplement que la république la
démocratie a besoin de l'argumentation
quand l'argumentation disparaît quand on
peut pratiquer des coups de force
sophistique eh bien je pense qu'on perd
quelque chose avait qu'à voir l'exemple
des états unis
alors j'ai lu la voilà j'allais y venir
la science on vient d'en débattre afin
d'en parler elle et elle est de plus en
plus remise en cause par des opinions
par ce qu'on appelle aussi les faits
alternatif et quand on parle de faits
alternatifs ont obligé de parler de
donald trump et de ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis avec la façon dont il
conteste les résultats de la
présidentielle en ce moment quel regard
vous portez sur ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis actuellement mais donald
trump il ne conteste pas la science
parce que pour la contester il faut la
connaître
il la connaît même pas ils s'en fichent
complètement c'est pas du tout dans son
référentiel il dit des choses absurdes
parfois dont le but sur le virus il a
quand même contesté à la séance 1 du
virus il ay la une il a une vision
directe du virus qui est meilleure que
celle des chercheurs qui eux font des
recherches chronophage inutile d'après
lui parce qu'il saisit qu'ils se
trompent ils ont besoin de protocoles
sophistiqués alors que lui a un instinct
direct du virus de même qu il a
l'instinct direct du climat et je pense
que cette invocation une forme de bon
sens de ressentir d'instinct comme il le
dit lui-même c'est quand même une très
très lourd de menaces parce que la
science elle c'est plus que de la
science moderne celle qui est née au
xviie siècle avec galilée s'est
construite contre le bon sens
les premières lois physiques sont des
lois qui contredisent l'observation par
exemple lequel il est dit que une grosse
pierre tombe à la même vitesse qu'une
petite pierre parler l'habitation
c'est parce qu'on voit et donc faire de
la science et ses pensées contre son
cerveau s'est pas dire ce qu'on pense
spontanément c'est au contraire
soumettre ce qu'on croit vrai un examen
critique qui peut aboutir à changer
d'avis mais si on est trop sûr de soi
aucune critique n'est plus efficace et
il change d'avis d'à peu près n'importe
quoi sur tous les sujets et ce qui
m'inquiète c'est pas du tout qu'il soit
comme il est c'est le fait que ça ne
suffise pas à lui fait peur
perdre tout crédit mais c'est ce que
j'allais vous dirais le mensonge c'est
la marque de fabrique de donald trump
comment vous expliquer qu'ils soient
plébiscités malgré ses mensonges énormes
le nommant dépasser un mystère pour moi
mais je dirais pas qu'ils m'ont parce
qu'un menteur connaît la vérité sauf si
les mythomanes merlin menteur continue
on sait qu'il ment lui c'est plutôt le
terme anglais c'est vous le connaissez
c'est bullshit
c'est n'importe quoi c'est et je suis
pas sûr que lorsqu'il dit ce genre
d'ineptie ils aient conscience de les
dire autrement dit c'est plus compliqué
que un simple mensonge systématique
merci beaucoup etienne klein d'être venu
sur le plateau de ça vous regarde je
rappelle le titre de votre ouvrage le
goût du vrai chez gallimard ça coûte 3
euros 90 et c'est donc passionnant merci
encore c'est l'heure de notre bloc-notes
[Musique]
et pour notre bloc-notes on prend
justement la direction des états unis
car l'actualité de la semaine c'est bien
sûr cette présidentielle américaine
bonsoir richard verdi alors vous êtes à
philadelphie je crois en paix nomme
pennsylvanie c'est évidemment l'un des
états clés vers lequel tous les tous les
regards se tournent vous nous avez fait
vivre ce feuilleton de la présidentielle
tout au long de cette semaine
à l'heure où l'on enregistre cette
émission dite no est-ce qu'on approche
de l'épi log
alors ça c'est incontestable on va vers
un épilogue d'ailleurs les chaînes
d'information américaines n'arrive pas
de dire qu'on est vraiment au bord de
l'annonce au bord de la confirmation de
la victoire de joe biden mais pour
l'instant ça ne vient pas pour une
raison assez simple c'est que les
décomptes dans les quatre états clés
alors je le rappelle on parle de
l'arizona on parle du nevada on parle de
la pennsylvanie où je me trouvais on
parle de la géorgie eh bien les
résultats ils sont d'abord pas finalisé
le décompte se poursuit mais surtout vu
le climat que vous avez invoqué sai
revue les attaques de donald trump qui
parlent de fraudes en permanence et bien
les collèges électoraux de ces quatre
états font vraiment tout pour être
irréprochable c'est ce qui explique
largement la lenteur du décompte final
et encore une fois c'est dans les heures
qui viennent on devrait savoir si joe
biden a franchi la fameuse barre et 270
bronzer
auteur qui lui donnera la victoire je
précise inquiet les 17 heures à l'heure
à laquelle on enregistre cette émission
alors vous nous aviez expliqué richard
concret n'est des troubles dans la rue
qu'est ce qu'il en est a à l'heure
actuelle
alors pour l'instant en tout cas dans la
ville de philadelphie où je me trouve
c'est très calme c'est important
philadelphie parce que la pennsylvanie
avec ses vingt grands électeurs est
véritablement le coeur de la
contestation de donald trump
il a besoin de cet état s'ils voulaient
s'il pouvait être élu et il lui faut
absolument démontrer qu'il y avait eu
fraude puisque ils avaient une avance de
sept cent mille voix dans la nuit
électorale qui a fondu au fur et à
mesure du dépouillement des votes par
correspondance et maintenant il est
devancé par joe biden en clair il a
perdu la pennsylvanie alors j'étais
fière comme vous le savez donc dans la
capitale de la pennsylvanie à harrisburg
et là c'était très intéressant de par et
d'autres du capitole il y avait d'un
côté les partisans de trump qui
réclamait l'arrêt du décompte et un
nouveau comptage il y avait de l'autre
ceux qui veulent que tous les votes
soient comptés c'est à dire les
démocrates parce qu'ils savent que ça va
leur donner la victoire
eh bien il n'y avait pas des chauffours
il n'y avait pas de violence on sent que
les deux camps se préparent mais
aujourd'hui et ça c'est une chance on ne
note pas de violences importantes en
amérique
même si il semble que nous deux
personnes ont été arrêtées armée mais on
n'est pas du tout face à un mouvement de
foule protestataires je dis bien pour le
moment alors de son côté donald trump
poursuit un peu sa guérilla judiciaire
c'est l'on peut dire qu'est ce qu'il
attend de ce combat alors donald trump a
tant de choses à travers ses
déclarations qui c'est important de le
noter sont exactement les mêmes que
celles qu'il fait depuis plusieurs mois
ils dénoncent aujourd'hui ce qu'il
dénonçait avant le scrutin à savoir les
votes par correspondance
petite anecdote il a voté lui même par
correspondance en floride en fait il
veut deux choses d'une part
idéalement il voudrait que ses avocats
puissent démontrer la fraude la fraude
c'est quelque chose d'intentionnel ça
prouve que des autorités d'un état donné
aurait décidé de le faire perdre ça bien
sûr pour lui ce serait la victoire
majeure mais c'est très peu probable car
il ya eu très peu de rapports
d'incidents ou de faute grave durant ce
scrutin
la deuxième chose qu'ils recherchent et
ça c'est vraiment sur quoi travaille ses
avocats notamment ceux que j'ai vus hier
harris bird s'est démontré que dans un
état donné le comptage n'a pas été bien
effectué qu il y a eu des irrégularités
ce qui permettrait point de demander un
nouveau record et points 2-2 le demander
aussi dans un autre état et si cet autre
état arrive avec une conclusion que le
comptage ne doit pas se faire de la même
manière à ce moment là la cour suprême
pourra s'en saisir la cour suprême aux
états unis peut intervenir lorsque deux
états sont en désaccord c'est ce que
cherche aujourd'hui donald trump
merci beaucoup richard et charvet et
puis bon courage parce qu'on a compris
que ça n'est pas fini on va reparler
dans les jours alors chez nos amis
britanniques à présent quel regard est
ce que l'on porte sur cette
présidentielle américaine
je rappelle donc qu'à l'heure qu'il est
alors à laquelle on enregistre cette
émission on ne sait pas encore si joe
biden va l'emporter mais il est quand
même très bien parti si c'est le cas
alex taylor ce serait une mauvaise
nouvelle pour boris james johnson et
pour pour sombrer exit le break 6 et oui
cette grande arlésienne
et là on parle du vrai que la composent
kahn quittera l'union douanière le
marché unique dont cette minuscule
semaine pour le moment les négociations
continuent enfin ça dépend un peu quel
tweet on lit car c'est très on and off
officiellement sous des questions
touchant à la pêche et au bouddha vous
plaît nous ferme les règles du jeu fair
play mais si l'on regarde derrière les
tweets chaque côté attendent tous
finalement de savoir outre atlantique
the winner is ailleurs cela changerait
quoi concrètement cela pas beaucoup le
moins que l'on puisse tirer que joe boyd
n'est pas franchement fan du parc site
lendemain du vote en 2016
il a twitté on aurait préféré un autre
résultat plutôt que la victoire de
démagogues brassant de l'asie 9 bis du
nationalisme et de l'isolationnisme
c'est déjà pas top mais à pire pour
johnson les origines irlandaises de
dubaï donne le ton les 5 8e du 100 sont
irlandais et il n'en est pas peu fier
écoutez ces extraits lors de ses visites
sur place selon un vieux dicton si on a
de la chance d'être irlandais eh bien on
a de la chance tout court une pendant la
grande famine de la pomme de terre ou
les britanniques maltraitait
terriblement les irlandais sans
plaisanterie on arrière arrière arrière
arrière grand père est monté dans un
navire en 1849 avec plusieurs membres de
sa famille je crois il également à
destination de la louisiane rigide puis
plus récemment byden a été visiblement
outré par la volonté de johnson de ne
pas respecter l'accord de sortie avec
l'union européenne
twitter on ne peut tolérer que l'accord
de paix en irlande dont je vous rappelle
que les états unis sont garants de
vienne la victime du break site tout
accord commercial
je suis toujours entre les etats-unis la
grande-bretagne dépendra du respect
accordé à celui ci c'est vrai qu'avec
cela johnson ne pourra plus continuer à
faire semblant qu'il n'y aura jamais de
frontière entre le royaume uni et
l'union européenne en irlande ce qui est
sa politique franchement pour le moment
puis pour finir on parle de ne porte pas
forcément johnson dans son coeur lorsque
celui ci était vice président johnson
avait attribué le côté anti brixi de son
boss obama au fait que les origines
kenyanes de celui ci lui aurait donné
une hargne contre l' empire britannique
bref même si johnson propose dans ses
moments les plus erratique de construire
un pont entre le royaume uni et
l'irlande du nord
le plus urgent serait peut-être celui
qui enjamberait et darbar ce que l'on
appelle le grand étang de bigpond
between washington and london
merci à vous alex alors camille saféris
et isabelle lasserre nous ont rejoint
bonsoir à tous les deux on commence par
vous isabella vous êtes rédactrice en
chef adjointe au service international
du figaro alors on a bien vu avec les
relations entre emmanuel macron et
donald trump avait été compliquée
pendant quatre ans pour autant est-ce
qu'à l'elysée
eh ben on préférerait une victoire de
joe biden alors en fait pour paris il
n'y a aucun bon vainqueur
alors bien sûr l'arrivée à la maison
blanche d'un candidat beaucoup plus
classique beaucoup plus ouvert aux
européens est une bonne nouvelle et
devrait redonner le sourire aux
responsables français
mais parce que en fait depuis son
arrivée à l'elysée emmanuel macron n'a
absolument pas réussi à influencer
donald trump mais il se faut se faire
aucune illusion
joe biden va reprendre le grand axe de
la politique étrangère américaine
celui qui fut aussi celui de d'obama et
qui est un retrait progressif des états
unis du moyen-orient et d'europe
il n'y aura absolument pas de retour au
business as usual l'amérique en 2020
changé elle n'est plus celle du début du
siècle et c'est un vrai véritable
changement donc à vous entendre on peut
se demander si finalement une réélection
de donald trump serait pas meilleure
chose pour le manuel macron écouter
s'est pas complètement exclue parce que
quand on analyse la situation on
s'aperçoit que emmanuel macron à tirer
profit du comportement erratique de
donald trump il s'est engouffré dans le
vide laissé par les états unis
il a appris la tête de toutes les
grandes initiatives européennes de ces
derniers mois par exemple en 2019 au g7
de biarritz c'est lui qui organisait la
visite surprise du ministre des affaires
étrangères iranien dans l'espoir d' dans
l'espoir de de débloquer une solution
sur le sujet du nucléaire
autre exemple c'était manuel macron qui
tient tête à erdogan
quand les états unis ne dise mot et le
laisse agir donc en tout étant on peut
tout à fait considérer que joe biden qui
a promis ne l'oublions pas de restaurer
le leadership américain veuille
reprendre ces grands dossiers de
politique étrangère à emmanuel macron et
ses fesses a du coup ça affaiblir et
l'europe c'est aussi un risque parce
qu'avec son ton poli et sympathique avec
eux son expérience avec son comportement
normal
joe biden pourrait
endormir les européens les joutes
destructrice de tron comme sa menace de
ne plus respecter la garantie de
sécurité au transatlantique avait enfin
provoqué un mini réveil des européens
qui commençait à comprendre qu'il ne
pouvait plus se dépendre entièrement à
100 % des états unis alors le risque
avec dubai donne c'est qu'une partie de
ces européens sur rue à washington et se
replacer illico sous le parapluie
sécuritaire américain futile perclus de
trous alors là l'autonomie stratégique
qui est quand même le grand projet
européen des manuels macro est à nouveau
renvoyé aux calendes grecques
et c'est ce qu'on a commencé à voir
d'ailleurs avec la ministre allemande de
la défense dans une tribune d'un
magazine politique au effectivement elle
souhaite à nouveau se mettre sous la
protection du bouclier nucléaire
c'est avec le premier pays qui se ruera
merci beaucoup isabelle alors on est
vendredi soir c'est l'heure de
l'apéritif
absolument c'est l'heure de la réglisse
et ferris alors aujourd'hui vous vous
prenez un verre avec bruno stauder vous
avez pris un verre était quand même dans
des conditions un petit peu différente
de celle d'aujourd'hui on va le préciser
à dos dans brüno suder député la
république en marche du bas rhin du bas
rhin enfin prof d'histoire-géo
absolument né à colmar il s'est mis en
disponibilité de paix depuis qu'il est
député et là où il y a deux ans il a
pris délibérément l'accent alsacien
l'hémicycle pour répondre à une roma
mais obligeant nos députés jean luc
mélenchon pour ne pas le nommer
sur l'action d'une journaliste alors
buzz bad buzz sur les réseaux etc
alors on est revenus ensemble sur cet
épisode mac et sur s'adresse aux mini
cité l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer
j'espère qu'elle sera intelligible
jusqu'au bout malgré mon accent alsacien
on va rappeler de gérer la chose c'était
le 24 octobre 18
vous avez pris donc l'accent alsacien
que je n'ai pas par ailleurs c'est ça
voilà je trouve que s'attaquer
comme ça à l'accent d'une personne mais
enfin c'est attaquer avec chose de très
intime qui paraît que vous connaissez
savait faire d'autres actions une fois
je sais pas ce que on va boire
maintenant mais j'ai commandé un petit
con il ya un quart d'heure sur pas là
ouais moyens voyage y'a pas le feu au
lac
c'est pas grave si l'on prend son temps
pour m'amener sans picon bière au mieux
ouais bah moi je vois quel genre
d'imitateur vous du dimanche
on a eu un meilleur imitateur que vous
avez reçus dans l'émission c'est
philippe gosselin il ya quelques
semaines
ah oui il était surtout a fait un numéro
alors vous aussi dire est très
sympathique mais c'est vrai que chacun
son répertoire un peu différent alors
bruno stud r il faut dire qu'il a eu la
copie du mois de mars il a perdu
l'odorat et ça lui a posé évidemment pas
des problèmes au quotidien
il ya des choses que je sens il ya des
choses que je sens pas et en particulier
notamment monod d'art corporel c'est une
chose que j'ai du mal à percevoir
du coup je demande à ma femme c'est
parfois pour me rassurer est ce que je
ressens pas la transpiration nommé en
fait comme j'ai vraiment perdu une
partie de doha à l'assemblée c'est
gênant de cet événement politique ne pas
avoir donné j'ai pas peur des mots et
j'ai perdu mon odorat
ouais pas dentition non j'espère pas
croyez si on espère que ça va ça va lui
revenir quand même on espère que c'est
le vallon du salut est peut-être venu de
depuis qu'on a tourné cet apéro alors
c'est d'autant plus il est d'autant plus
concernée par ce parce cette chose-là
bono c'est dire qui vient à l'assemblée
en vélo électrique c'est un vrai l'acien
c'est et il ya vire but qui a six vélos
électriques actuellement qui viennent
d'être mis en service à l'assemblée
c'est un peu comme des vélib mais dédié
uniquement aux députés alors je le dis
parce que moi je l'aï appris je ne
savais pas quand je pense les gens ne le
savent pas alors évidemment question
célèbre question rituelle à l'ats michel
chevalet comment ça marche
ah c'est mieux que les vélib mais c'est
moins bien que ce que j'ai à et vous
faites du conte bien avec ça s'est
limité à 25 à 25 l'assistance avec une
star est assez vrai
puisque c'est la loi c'est la loi nul
n'est censé ignorer là ça va plus c'est
une nouveauté à l'assemblée les députés
peuvent se servir des vélos en libre
service
c'est ça j'étais convaincu que vélo
électrique ça allait ça allait
révolutionner les transports avait
raison j'ai souvent raison il est un
beau vélo mais pas très modeste non non
mais il a beaucoup d'humour il est
vraiment sympa de cette faute et au jeu
bon bah merci
camille merci à tous les deux merci
isabelle c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à vous téléspectateurs de votre
fidélité tout de suite le grand retour
de des confinés sur lcp avec maïtena
biraben prenez soin de vous un bon week
end
bonne soirée sur lcp
[Musique]